Bienvenidos a economía de fin de semana
en France 24 yo soy Daniela Blandón esta
semana se reunieron en Washington los
principales líderes económicos en los
encuentros de primavera del fondo
monetario internacional y del Banco
Mundial los principales prestamistas del
mundo hicieron sus apuestas en torno a
lo que viene para la economía en una
coyuntura de altísimos precios que son
combatidos por los bancos centrales con
alzas de intereses también un colapso de
algunos bancos pequeños en Estados
Unidos que puso al mercado con los
nervios de punta y un peligro de
recesión que sigue latente para conocer
cómo se están abordando estas
problemáticas en el seno del fondo
monetario internacional conectamos con
Gustavo adler él es el jefe de estudios
regionales para el hemisferio occidental
de este organismo multilateral Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos en France 24
después de una intensa semana de
conversaciones en Washington
Muchas gracias y realmente un placer
estar aquí Bueno pues Comencemos por
hablar del crecimiento económico de la
región que tuvo un mejor desempeño que
el mundo en general el año pasado pero
para 2023 y 2024 como observaremos en el
gráfico se espera una fuerte
desaceleración y en general la
perspectiva es muy pesimista debido
principalmente a los temores que hay
sobre una posible recesión que
impactaría directamente la demanda sobre
las materias primas que producimos en la
región entre otros Por qué entonces el
año pasado el crecimiento fue tan
destacado
bueno claramente la región fue muy
resiliente en el 2022 pero refleja una
serie de factores en gran medida
externos
por un lado hay que tener en cuenta que
la región fue una de las más afectadas
en el mundo en el 2020 a raíz de la
pandemia y hubo un efecto rebote
importante tanto en el 2021 como en el
2022 entonces parte del Fuerte
crecimiento que vimos en el 2022 se debe
a ese espacio que había para que la
economía rebote después de haber caído
tan fuertemente durante la pandemia
Pero también es importante reconocer que
la el shock de la invasión de Rusia a
Ucrania tuvo efectos distintos en la
región que en el resto del mundo por un
lado hubo un shock de oferta en la
producción de de energía y alimentos y
eso fue un shock negativo para gran
parte del mundo con efectos contractivos
y por supuesto en parte también para la
región Pero por otro lado la región
tiene productores de alimentos de
energía también muy importante que se
vieron beneficiados por esto entonces de
alguna forma esto hizo que la región
tuviera un efecto menos negativo
respecto del resto del mundo en términos
de contracción o de desaceleración
durante el 2022 y justamente una de las
propuestas que han hecho ustedes desde
el fondo monetario internacional es
Elevar impuestos a los ricos ve posibles
su implementación en los países del
continente
ahora es importante tener
poner un poco de contexto nuestra
nuestra Visión Es que la política fiscal
tiene que tener una una postura un poco
más contractiva no solo para ayudar a
los bancos centrales a convertir la
inflación en el corto plazo sino porque
es necesario también reconstruir
márgenes de maniobra para tener espacio
para hacerle frente a shocks futuro de
hecho durante la pandemia se hizo mucho
gasto fiscal necesario bien hecho y esa
fue una forma de hacer política fiscal
contra cíclica cuando uno está en la
etapa buena del ciclo positiva del ciclo
tiene que hacer lo contrario y
reconstruir espacio fiscal hizo lo que
estamos diciendo Cómo se hace esto en un
contexto donde las demandas sociales son
muy muy fuertes hay que preservar gasto
social clave gasto en salud gasto en
educación y en infraestructura y hay que
buscar lugares donde se pueda mejorar la
eficiencia del gasto eso es clave pero
pero también hay que buscar mejoras por
el lado de la recaudación tributaria y
de aumentar los recursos tributarios y
en ese sentido hacer los sistemas
impositivos de la región más progresivo
es un elemento clave nosotros creemos
que la medida que
haya mejoras en la eficiencia y en Cómo
se gastan los dineros públicos va a
haber apetito en las sociedades para
también contribuir más y que los que más
tienen pongan su parte señora ustedes
presentaron toda un informe regional que
también habla de que el control de la
inflación es una tarea no solamente de
los bancos centrales sino también de los
gobiernos Qué estrategias se pueden
implementar en la región en ese sentido
el instrumento principal para hacer
frente y controlar la inflación y de
hecho los bancos centrales de la región
la han usado muy efectivamente
subiendo tasas muy rápidamente a medida
que se vieron presiones inflacionarias
pero es importante que otros
instrumentos de política económica no
vayan en contramano y en lo posible que
ayuden a la política monetaria y ahí es
donde vemos que la política fiscal puede
tener un rol más decisivo para ser más
preciso hay que pensar Cómo funciona la
política monetaria y el mecanismo
principal es básicamente controlar la
demanda interna subiendo tasas
básicamente se desestimula un poco el
consumo y la inversión para que
desaceleren Y ese es el mecanismo
principal de la política monetaria la
política fiscal puede tener efectos
similares sobre la demanda interna y por
eso es que decimos que tiene que tiene
que ayudar y eso es central para que no
tener un período de tasas de interés muy
altas por mucho tiempo que pueden llevar
a a otros problemas de estabilidad de la
deuda pública de efectos en la hoja de
balance de los de las firmas y también
efectos en las hojas de balance de los
bancos y en ese sentido ha sido efectivo
el aumento de tasas de interés para
controlar la inflación esta estrategia
funciona por el lado de la demanda Pero
qué se puede hacer desde el lado de la
oferta
bueno en términos de efectividad la
política monetaria es claramente
efectiva y nuestros estudios muestran
por ejemplo que una suba de un 1% de
tasas de interés trae aparejado una
menor inflación de aproximadamente medio
punto porcentual esto no pasa
inmediatamente lleva tiempo en general
lleva del orden de 12 a 18 meses y por
eso es que vemos Que creemos que los
efectos de las tasas altas que se verán
mayoritariamente este año
pero sí es verdad que se puede hacer
cosas por el lado de la oferta también
en el corto plazo sin embargo hay que
reconocer que el principal efecto sobre
la demanda agregada Y eso Y eso se hace
con política monetaria pero en el
mediano plazo se puede afectar precios
también con con la oferta y ahí hay una
serie de recomendaciones que nosotros en
general damos de la primera es dejar que
los precios que el sistema de precios
refleje lo que va bienes y servicios en
ese sentido es importante que la energía
los alimentos reflejen su Su costo real
y su escasez esto es importante porque
es la forma de incentivar al sector
privado a producir más los bienes que
que son caros Entonces ese es un
elemento central Pero por supuesto
también se puede fomentar la producción
sacando barreras existente a la
producción al transporte y que sabemos
que en algunos casos la región son
importantes sobre todo donde hay cuellos
de botella de infraestructura o sea
habla de recomendaciones y otra
generales seguir subiendo las tasas de
interés no podría esto llegar a afectar
la economía
bueno a ver yo diría las tasas ya se han
subido fuertemente desde que empezó el
ciclo de endurecimiento de política
monetaria y creemos que en la gran
mayoría de los países Ya llegó la tasa
de interés a su pico es decir que ahora
además una cuestión de mantenerla al
nivel donde están hasta que se vea
decisivas una decisiva baja de la
inflación no
O sea que no vemos que que vaya a haber
un endurecimiento más fuerte de la
política monetaria en la mayoría de los
casos Pero por supuesto los bancos
centrales van a tener que estar atentos
a posibles presiones inflacionarias
nuevas incluyendo por ejemplo de la suba
de petróleo que de los precios de
petróleo que hemos visto recientemente
Como le decía antes esto opera vía
principalmente la demanda agregada Y es
importante para equilibrar la demanda
con la capacidad de producción de la
economía y ese es el mecanismo central
pero cuáles son esos factores que están
impactando y la inflación sobre todo la
inflación subyacente ya nos explicará En
qué consiste Cómo por ejemplo la guerra
en Ucrania todavía está impactando a las
economías de América Latina
para ser concreto es la parte de la
canasta de consumo que no incluye
alimentos y energía que tienen a ser
mucho más volátiles y lo que vemos ahí
Es que las presiones inflacionarias
siguen siendo bastante importantes en la
región más que nada producto de que la
demanda agregada interna sigue creciendo
muy fuerte y el empleo se ha recuperado
a niveles o incluso por arriba de
niveles de pre pandemia cómo le afecta a
la región el conflicto en Ucrania base
básicamente diría que en este momento
el efecto principal se debe a la a
las tensiones geopolíticas que estamos
viendo en el mundo y que están teniendo
efectos sobre la actividad económica
global y a través de eso la demanda
externa para la región Ese es el efecto
principal en el corto
usted habla de empleo y últimamente se
ha visto que un mercado laboral más
Dinámico tiende a ser una mala noticia
entre comillas para los países Cómo se
explica esta situación
a ver un mercado laboral Dinámico
siempre siempre es buena noticia y en
ese sentido Es bueno Es bueno que así
sea lo que estamos viendo en la región
Pero también es el caso que cuando la el
empleo ya está a su nivel
potencial que es lo que hemos visto los
recuperados el empleo ya a niveles pre
pandemia significa que la economía ya
está produciendo a pleno que que no
existe mucha más capacidad al menos en
el corto plazo en ese contexto cuando la
demanda agregada continúa acelerando muy
fuerte genera presiones vía salarios y
precio y eso genera inflación y como
sabemos eso tiende a afectar a los más
pobres y a los más vulnerables por eso
es que es importante estabilizar precios
y a veces eso requiere un poco
desacelerar la demanda y enfriar un poco
el mercado laboral
señor Gustavo battler director Regional
del hemisferio occidental del fondo
monetario internacional Gracias por
atender nuestra invitación
un placer cuenten conmigo cuando quieran
a ustedes también gracias por su
sintonía los esperamos acá en France 24
también en France 24 punto com